to the brink of extinction for it's
salable horn and now the last surviving
male northern white rhino is being kept
over 24-hour armed guard in a desperate
attempt to save the species well joining
me now is Kathy Dean director of the
charity save the Rhino let's have a look
at Sudan this is the this is the Rhino
now tell us a bit about him so his the
very last male northern white as you
said his 43 years old which I'm afraid
makes some geriatric in Rhino terms he
was originally caught in southern Sudan
a couple of decades ago he spent many
years at fur krylova zoo in the Czech
Republic and in 2010 he was moved
together with three other rhinos 12
pajetta Conservancy so where is he now
in old pajetta which is sort of on the
equator in Kenya so much more natural
habitat for him the hope was that he
would want to revive his interest in
mating with the otherwise wise his horn
kind of you know there rub down totally
its own safety obviously poachers are
killing rhinos three at least three
animals killed every day for their horn
so that is for his safety of his
protection okay well let's look at some
of the statistics about rhinos white
rhino they're 20,000 of them they're
more 20,000 southern white rhino but
this is particularly the northern white
rhino and only five and any one male
that's right that's right it's a really
sorry situation to be in an easy to old
to be bred from yeah he is I'm afraid
geriatric and but unfortunately the
other northern white rhino females are
also either too old or they've got
reproductive problems they've got cysts
on their tracks they're also related to
him did the other two females with him
in Kenya one is his daughter one's his
granddaughter that's not a lot of
genetic variance they're going to die
out of it I'm afraid I think it looks
that way I mean really the only hope is
to preserve genetic material sperm news
sites and so on freeze them and perhaps
in 20 years time scientists will be
ready to try assisted reproductive
technology I mean a dramatic increase in
in the
Mountain rhinos being killed from just
six in 2002-2014 why is that happening
its demand for the horn particularly
coming from Vietnam probably also from
Asia but essentially a rich successful
businessman want to display how wealthy
they are so they buy the horn they may
not consume it they may not grind it up
and drink it they might just stick it on
a mantelpiece to show I can afford a
horn this big Japanese your ivory is it
you don't love it it's just like
fingernails you don't actually in
ancient China they carved ornamental
bowls libation cups from it it was
supposed to react with poison so Empress
could tell whether their drinks were
safe but actually there's no medicinal
value it's inert it's like our
fingernail means it's supposed to be an
aphrodisiac or something no that's a
Western myth although actually our
Western myth is now translating back
into Vietnam and they're taking it for
all sorts of reasons
and this is the the sad figure really
that the number of killings deaths is
just about overtaking I actually it's
going to be this year the South African
government released stats just on on
Sunday saying that already if in the
first four months of this year nearly
400 animals were so what what can be
done I mean how I mean is it really
credible to just keep this on guard on
for 24 hours not not on a one-to-one
basis like this like this no country can
afford it it's a whole mixture of
solutions it's it's increased protection
political will increasing sentences but
it's also about reducing demand for
rhino horn particularly in Vietnam so we
launched a behavior change campaign we
believe it will work it worked in the
80s and 90s during the last poaching
crisis but it's going to take a couple
years and then a similar thing is
happening with elephants as well for
ivory for ornamental hanko seals so that
run sign your name you stick you stamp
it with an ivory seal it's a ridiculous
reason to see the extinction of whole
species and this is basically because
there isn't a rule of law or the rule
nor is diminishing in large parts of
Africa it's not that so much it's just
it the criminal syndicates if you can
smoke if you can traffic humans across
orders you can smuggle drugs you can
smuggle weapons something pretty small
like a rhino horn is very easy and
they're putting fast
resources fast effort and it you know
we're talking mafia triad people like
that they're not soft opposition Kathy
thank you very much thank you